hey it's Justine and today we're
unboxing the brand new DJI osmo pocket 3
this little camera has been one of my
favorites over the past couple of years
and I'm so excited they now have a brand
new version for us to check out ooh a
nice little case let's open up this
little case first this is so nice and it
feels like one of those dry bags so it
can keep it safe and away from any
liquid
damage what this is so cute and
organized
protective cover so we have the pocket
itself here it
is so we've got our little battery
handle here we've got our micro oh my
goodness look how nice this looks it's
all seethrough so what's cool about this
is this does have a built-in transmitter
so if you do want to use a microphone
with it you can use the little
transmitter and this will act as the
receiver so you don't need any
additional cables it's already built in
which is awesome and these handles are
really easy to use you just plug them in
with USBC see magnetic little mic clip
we'll just keep you with your friend
look at this mini tripod it's so cute I
can't believe all the stuff fits in this
bag jeez there's still more we've got
the little wind wig to put on top of our
microphone wrist strap very
[Music]
nice I can't believe how much stuff came
in this tiny little bag and it all fits
perfectly now that everything's unboxed
I'm going to set it up and take it out
to start
testing
[Music]
so I'm now outside testing out the new
osmo pocket 3 and this thing has by far
exceeded my expectations like I've used
the past two generations and they were
cool but there is something about this
that just feels feels perfected I feel
like when we get into the third gen of
any type of tech cameras drones phones
this is where they really have the
ability to refine all of the things that
were wrong with previous versions and
make them right so this one has me so
excited to create content and especially
for vertical and short form content
creators I think this is going to be
such a win for them and me I also create
that as well so this has a 1-in sensor
that lets you shoot up to 4K 120 frames
per second it's got improved low light
with night shots and the ability to
shoot in 10bit dlog m and 10 bit hlg
color modes for more control when
coloring and post the focus on this
feels so much faster and it even has
product showcase mode that will focus on
a subject quickly and smoothly the
stabilization is also incredible and in
this video you can see I'm running
really fast on the beach and it's so
steady you can also choose from
different rotational speeds to suit
whatever scenario you're in much like
other DJI products this has active track
6.0 which gives you different types of
follow modes like face Auto detect and
dynamic framing the sound on this is
also pretty impressive which I really
like because I can just take this out I
don't need to have anything else but
this does have an integration with the
new DJI mic 2 the receiver is already
built in so you can just use one of the
transmitter mics and you're good to go
okay so here is what it sounds like
without using a microphone I'm in my
studio it's a little bit echoey so when
I turn this on it's going to connect
automatically and you can hear what this
sounds like test test testing one two
three okay so here it is I'm now talking
on the DJI mic 2 how does it sound I
also have the tracking on so it's
tracking my face so no matter where I go
like it's going to it's going to keep me
in check if you do have the DJI mic pack
one that will also work with this but
you will need to plug in the receiver
those things have been my microphone
go-to for filming on the go and also
when I'm filming with my iPhone I can
just plug that receiver in and it works
perfectly this has a built-in three mic
array that reduces wind noise and
Records omnidirectional stereo to give
your viewers an even more immersive
experience it does support USB external
microph phones and headphones to monitor
audio now the highlight of this video
which you may have seen in some of the
b-roll shots already is the fact that
you can flip this little screen flip now
with that it'll automatically switch it
into shooting in vertical which makes
filming with this so incredible I can be
filming in WID screen and then within
not even a second I can flip this and be
filming a vertical video as well I think
this is going to be so key for so many
creators because this gives you the
ability to quickly shoot both this
little storage case is also my favorite
I love it because you have a little
section here to store some of the
filters so in here I have a wideangle
lens and a black promis filter and these
are also magnetic so it's so easy to pop
them right onto the lens on the go oh
and did I mention that it also takes
photos I tend to forget about taking
photos when I'm reviewing cameras mostly
just because I'm such a video person
that photos is not usually on my mind
but when I first started taking some
photos with this as was absolutely Blown
Away by the quality it's also pretty
cool because this is a gimbal you can
take really cool panorama photos because
the Gimbal and camera just moves right
around and gets the perfect shot
something else that I love is being able
to use this with the DJI mimo app I can
connect this to my phone and download
all my videos and photos and share them
instantly on social or if you're like me
and love editing on your iPhone you can
also start editing all of your content
right there DJI also has some really
cool AI features so I really love that
they give you all of these options
inside of the app and it gives people
flexibility who may not be video editors
the chance to really create and make
something really cool and sh share it
immediately so yeah my friends that is
the DJI osmo pocket 3 I am so impressed
with it and if you're a content creator
like I swear you could probably just get
away with having this this is it you've
got this you've got your little log
microphone you'll be good to
go